[Music]
if we do all this
if we do our part if we do this together
by july the fourth there's a good chance
you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
that doesn't mean large events with lots
of people together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together i'll tell you the truth
a july 4th with your loved ones
is the goal but a goal
a lot can happen conditions can change
that was uh the address last night from
the president let's bring in house
minority leader kevin mccarthy good
morning to you
good morning good morning so when you
heard that what was your reaction my
reaction was
july hopefully we'll be back to normal
but i know he was a party planner
look i was hoping it was going to
inspire americans not try to intimidate
us
you know instead of denouncing china he
tried to discredit
operation warp speed i was actually
waiting for him to actually take
credit for inventing the internet too
you know if i want to celebrate i can go
to florida
or texas today and if we're going to
have all this by may 1st why do we have
to wait another two months
yeah good point it was frustrating to me
you know one of the things he did later
uh yesterday that was good for a lot of
people was he said that by may 1st
every adult who wants a shot should be
able to
register to get one doesn't mean they
can get it by may 1st but but register
and he's opening it up he's going to
make it possible for dentists to give it
and paramedics and
veterinarians and we were talking about
we were talking to geraldo about that
about an hour ago and i joked i don't
know about a veterinarian
a veterinarian but because i've never
gotten a shot from a vet but if that's
the
listen they'd give good shots i was
joking obviously
but if that is how we reopen our economy
by trying to flood the zone with as many
shots as possible
people should roll up their sleeves and
get the shot right
yes they should but how is he able to
provide that shot
operation warp speed he also said when
he got into office that they didn't have
the vaccine until he came in even though
he was already
vaccinated let's give credit where
credit is due because
it is the american ingenuity that came
together
that we had a virus hit us from china
that we came together
and made vaccines now there's three out
there that's already approved so we're
going to be
we're producing more than 2 million a
day into people's arms
i say every american that want the
vaccine should get it but also
every american should be able to go back
to work back to school and back to
health
the other thing that he's going to do
he's going to sign a bill
that's going to cost every family of
four 22
000 and the thing he's not telling you
is what's in this bill let me just point
out
three things what your hard working
taxpayers money is going for
you are now going to provide bonuses up
to twenty five thousand dollars
to government employees and bureaucrats
if you're not part of the swamp
you get nothing you are now your money's
going to pay for
illegal immigrants health care your
money also is being sent to san
francisco city
where your money will be spent giving
alcohol and marijuana to the homeless
that is what that bill is doing and
two-thirds of the money for the schools
don't even come forward to 2023 and
there's a trillion dollars still
sitting there from the five bills we've
already passed
this is a waste of money less than nine
percent is going to covet
this is a payoff to pelosi's political
friends
and if she's going to go if they're
going to go around and try to get
momentum behind the 1.9 trillion they
should go to prisons because uh
prisoners are getting some money for
this too so that should be great i want
to talk about where's that
brian but where's that money coming from
it's your hard-working taxpayer
of course every american should know it
you just got a bill for 22
000 and that's what your money is being
spent on so let's talk about one should
know it and tell their elected officials
so here's what nancy pelosi says
because this passed and there's no
republican support she claims that you
guys are trying to deflect
listen to what she said yesterday
when you have been focused on covet the
republicans have been talking about
immigration when you were focused on the
voting rights act they were talking
about
immigration today you're talking about
fight for 15 today
they're talking about immigration i'm
wondering if house democrats or
you guys why are you why are we not
seeing the same thing
is this a distraction on their part i
guess their dr
zeus approach didn't work for them so
now they've had to change the subject
well i i guess she started referring to
the cancer culture when they knocked out
some children's books
what's your response to her well my
response to her
look what has happened in the short
amount of time they've controlled all
your gasoline prices up biden's created
a crisis on the border that he won't
admit
100 000 illegal immigrants were
encountered just last month
put that in perspective that is larger
than the hometown of scranton
pennsylvania of our president biden
and now it's only growing month after
month he tears the wall down in a border
but he puts it around the capitol
now he's eliminated almost a million
jobs into the energy sector
making our adversary stronger russia and
china
he won't denounce china when they
provided a virus to the entire world
iran is now doing naval tests
with russia they're sending missiles
into iraq
china is pushing the envelope into japan
and others
in taiwan and we're sitting here with
the president
that won't take questions for the last
50 days from the american public
to answer why do we have a crisis at the
border
last week i sent him a letter to sit
down and have a meeting on it
he still has not answered i'm going to
the border on monday i'm taking 12
other members with me so we can actually
solve this problem if the president
wants to continue to try to create it
and ignore it
facilities sorry good question well i
think it's going to be kind of difficult
for them if there's 12 members of
congress who fund these facilities that
they won't allow in
i know they've taken away the coveted
restrictions for these children if you
want to fly into america today
you've got to show that you've been
vaccinated or had a test right but
as they're letting the illegal
immigrants into our country
there's no test required they're letting
them right on in
to compete with the 10 million americans
who are out of work
that's what we've got with after this
election all right well after you go
down to the border on monday please come
back and tell us what you saw
glad to do it